I'd like to now calculate
the angular momentum of a two
particle system.
So here's one particle.
Call that 1.
And here's the other particle 2.
And particle 1 has a momentum
in the downward direction.
And particle 2 has a momentum
in the upper direction.
Now, in this case, I want to
make some of the momentum--
so this momentum
of the system is 0.
And now I want to calculate
the angular momentum
about two different points.
So let's just draw an axis here.
And let's choose one point A.
And we'll call this distance r,
and this distance r.
And let's choose
another point B,
and we'll call that distance d.
Now, in order to calculate
angular momentum of the system,
I need to draw my vectors.
Let's start with
the angular momentum
about the point A. That's going
to be a vector from A to object
1, cross the momentum of 1, plus
the vector from A to object 2,
cross the momentum of 2.
Now what's crucial
here, is at this point,
things are a little
bit of a abstract,
but we want to draw these
vectors, rA1 and rA2.
So we're now constructing our
angular momentum diagrams.
So there's rA1, and there rA2.
but again, in order
to calculate this,
we could do it geometrically
with right hand rules,
but I now want to
introduce unit vectors,
so I can do vector
decomposition at every point.
So I'm going to choose a
unit vector, i-hat, j-hat,
and k-hat.
And now I can decompose
all of these vectors
in terms of my unit vectors.
This is the angular
momentum of the system.
So now it's not hard at
all to write these out.
rA1 is minus r in
the i-hat direction.
Cross P1 is down.
That's minus P1 in
the j-hat direction,
where P1 is the magnitude .
And rA2 is in the
plus i-hat direction.
So that's r i-hat.
And I'm crossing
that with P2, which
I'll write right now as
P2 in the j-hat direction.
Now remember, P2 has the
same magnitude as P1,
but they're pointing
in opposite directions.
So when I take
the cross project,
i-hat cross j-hat is k-hat
minus sign minus sign.
So I get rP1 k-hat.
And now over here,
P2 is equal to P1.
i-hat cross j-hat is k-hat.
And I get another rP1 k-hat.
And so I have 2rP1 k-hat.
And that's the angular momentum
of the system about point A.
Now I'd like to calculate the
angular momentum about B So
let's draw the
same diagram, 1, 2.
Here is P2.
Here's P1.
Here is B. And now
I'll draw my vectors.
This is rB2 and this is rB1.
This distance was 2r.
This distance was d.
I'm going to use the
same unit vectors.
And so I get l for the
system about B. Again,
I'll just write everything out.
P1 plus rB2 cross P2.
So I'm going to write
P2 as, in this case,
it's equal to minus P1.
And magnitudes P2 equals P1.
In magnitude directions
are opposite.
So rB1 is equal 2r plus D
i-hat, and it's pointing
in the minus i-hat direction.
Cross P1 is in the
minus j-hat direction.
rB2 is also in the
minus i-hat direction,
so that's minus D i-hat.
And P2 is in the plus j
direction, so that is plus--
the magnitudes are the same--
P1 j-hat.
We don't need the
plus sign there.
And now I take the
cross products.
i-hat cross j-hat is k-hat.
A minus sign minus sign.
That makes plus.
So I have 2r plus D P1 k-hat.
Now notice here I have i-hat
cross j-hat, which is k-hat,
but there's a minus sign.
So I have minus D P1 k-hat.
Here I have plus D P1
k-hat minus D1 P k-hat.
And so I get 2rP1 k-hat.
And I have the same result.
L system A equals L system B.
Now that's not a
coincidence in this problem.
And the reason is
that whenever--
so we can say it this way.
Whenever the momentum
of the system is 0,
then LA is independent of
the choice of the point A.
So coming back to our
example, no matter where
I picked our points A and B--
any point I could
pick, anywhere I want--
I could pick a
point C up there--
I make this cross
product calculation.
I would get exactly
the same answer, 2rP1k.